i agree but
i read your chapter on how to not give
an f
and i find it very hard to
stop caring about what others think like
why
i don't know if you read this
chris did yes situation he basically
got hooked up with chicks who were
younger but at the legal age then
all the social media kept going at him
so
he got in a little bit of trouble and
also
that navigating the workplace like a
dude in my
mid 20s it's kind of hard just reading
about the red pill
and trying to apply it in the workforce
but also not
to be so uh you know
uh hr department the corporate
s and all this stuff it's kind of
okay okay let me just guide you here so
we can get to the uh
question on this part of giving fewer f
so the
the chapter that you're referencing i'm
talking about managing
your energy as a valuable resource
aka your [ __ ] and only dispensing them
for things that are truly [ __ ] worthy
so what's your question around that like
you're having a hard time
valuing it as a resource or what is it
exactly
i'm having a hard time not stop worrying
about others
or what they will think or what
ramifications i'm gonna get later
how old are you mo i'm pushing 24.
you're 24. where do you live again
sweden sweden okay
so um
at some point you've got to realize that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
women society the government your
employer
you like men are disposable generally
speaking
and women are protected because they
have more value than men on the sexual
marketplace
you know sperm is cheap eggs are
expensive blah blah blah i can go right
down the list
so you're spending like you're
you're not going to be able to manage
your f's and dispense them for things
that are worthy of said
f's if you don't value your f's so
if you have gas in the tank of your car
and it's half full
and you got to get somewhere that's
probably going to use that amount of gas
you're not going to be smashing the
pedal to the floor at every single light
and
breaking abruptly and flying around
corners and going faster than you should
because you're gonna
get shitty mileage right so you're gonna
value the gases in your tank and you're
gonna
use it appropriately in accordance with
the distance you have to travel in the
way that you have to drive the car
right so i mean i did this the other
night it was cold as [ __ ] hell out
and i
didn't feel like pumping gas out into
the car
it said that i had like 80 kilometers
range and the distance that i had to
travel to get home was something like
i don't know 50 kilometers i wasn't
smashing the gas
i valued the gas that i had in the tank
as a resource
so i used it in a fashion that was in
accordance with me
looking at the value that was in the gas
tank sort of thing so
you have to stop caring about maybe the
guy that's tailgating you
you have to stop caring about you know
the guy that maybe needs to you know
pull in and merge because you're
traveling at a certain speed because you
don't feel like getting out of the car
and freezing your balls off putting gas
in the car
at like -25 and you don't have gloves or
a hat in your car or anything like that
i don't care right like when you see
these things as a limited resource
that you can only dispense on things
that are important then you will start
to treat it that way
but you're not seeing is it a limited as
a limited resource which is probably why
you keep you know caring too much about
everybody else
and what they think of things does that
make sense i think it's just plain with
my mind that i saw
your tweet that got everybody talking
about these
six points that a woman should do and
i saw the fallback i'm like if i did the
same
thing or or i know you're on
your own business so you can afford to
not care about them
yeah but what if as a younger person or
a person just starting his life
listen you know whenever i put out a uh
tweet like that and for
those of you that don't know what it is
that are watching that that haven't seen
me use this
i mean if you go out onto twitter right
now and you say something like
ladies here's the five things you need
to do to keep a man
uh nobody likes them bad know how to
feed them look feminine
keep your hairs you know keep your hair
and makeup nice um
don't be a nag you know like standard
like standard stuff like
you know a grandmother would have told a
granddaughter like 50 years ago just
conventional stuff nothing out of the
ordinary right well
twitter loses its [ __ ] mind when you
do that there was probably about 20
articles that was written on me i was on
different news stations
around the world different parts of the
world all over the world and people were
basically like look at this incel
you know telling women what to do how
dare he and blah blah blah pointing and
sputtering
i laugh at it there's guys out there
like moe right now who might look at
that and be like oh my god all these
people have opinions of me that i don't
know what to do with and
they don't like me so how do i re you
have to get yourself to
to the point of zen not giving a [ __ ]
and i'm at the point of zen not giving
[ __ ] part of
part of which because i'm older than you
are and
i'm also a lot more anti-fragile than
you like nobody can fire me
right like i i had people that would
come in and be like oh are you richard
cooper of this company of blood was like
yeah [ __ ] i'm the ceo so go complain if
you want
nobody's firing me oh you're a customer
you don't like it [ __ ] off i don't care
right that's my opinion if you have a
problem my opinion then get lost
you know it's as simple as that that's
just the way that you can get to
when you start recognizing that your
energy is valuable
and you only should dispense your energy
aka your f's for things that are truly f
worthy
do i care of the opinion of all these
morons that are writing articles and
putting me on tv calling me names
i don't you know what happened guys like
you saw it and were like that's
interesting let me see who this guy is
and then you found my material so
they're actually doing me a favor
by marketing to the world for free
because i make a list of five things
that women should do to keep men happy
and they're outraged so
a big thing too i call it um
good chimpanzee right and i call it
uh useful or valuable chimpanzee
so women and less valuable
or beta males okay they're concerned
about being good chimpanzees
they want to know what the society
around them
you know how they accept them how they
feel about them this has to do with
evolutionary drives you know women
were able to survive based on theirs in
their
social status and standing in the tribe
or
had to do with the social opinions of
people around them
when people perceive them as being a
good mom a good person or whatever
and this is the root of like why in an
argument for example women don't
like to admit that they're wrong or mitt
fault it's not because and they do
sometimes but they they're handicapped
in doing that if they think it's gonna
make them be a bad chimpanzee you know
what i mean now guys though
alpha guys they just want to be they
want to provide value to the tribe
so when they're providing value they can
be the [ __ ]
they don't care you know what i mean
they'll they're the the guy who
defends the tribe and kicks everyone's
ass and is kind of an [ __ ] though
back in the rear nobody's kicking that
guy out in fact they're praising him
you know what i mean the best hunter if
he's kind of a dick
nobody cares they're praising him for
what he does
so rich is you know to use that
uh analogy he was a he's a valuable
chimpanzee
right what he does in the world and the
impact in the world
is huge so that's why he doesn't give a
[ __ ] you see what i'm saying
when you are know that you're bringing a
lot of value
to yourself to your tribe to people
around you into the world making that
dent
doesn't matter what people think matters
a lot less you care a lot less about
that
now you're a young guy i can tell so
you're probably at the lowest point
of value that you're going to be in your
life when you hit about 35 years old you
keep working on your [ __ ] not worrying
about what other people think
your value that you bring is going to be
a lot higher and then you're not going
to care so much about what other people
are thinking
so a real practical thing or practical
exercise
is to start doing things that are going
to provide value to yourself to others
or build your value once you start
building that value
it's easier to not give an f about what
other people think
you know so what you mean is that i have
to act like i'm part of them like
the male feminist beta beta
that's not what paul said so when you're
when you're looking for the validation
of other people
that's a feminine behavior that's a
female behavior
um it's an evolved piece of their
firmware for
survival because i mean part of the
reason why women today
are are are so drunk on attention on
social media like on instagram or tick
tock doing these dances and they're
dancing around like [ __ ] monkeys
trying to get everybody's validation and
likes and comments
is because it's hardwired into their
firmware from millions of years ago
because if they didn't have the approval
of the tribe
what would happen they'd get thrown out
can they survive on their own
the chances of them doing it are not as
high as a guy that has the ability to
you know do the things that guys can do
because they're stronger and they're
more capable for a gathering and often
women would have children so
that's also a disadvantage for them to
you know be carrying that around if
they're thrown out of the tribe
so when you're caring too much about
what other people think
that's more on the feminine sort of the
behavior scale it's not masculine it's
not alpha
it's a beta behavior so when you find
yourself like
oh well that person thinks that you know
this of me
just understand that that you're
thinking at a vibrational level
that's not an alpha male's level right
let's say a workplace that is very
uh progressive and very brave alike
and feminine in their approach should i
just
go under the radar and be like okay i'll
be
like we have will you have two sorry
you've got three choices
comply shut the [ __ ] up and mind your
own business
and just carry on knowing what you know
and not offering your opinion because
it's kind of pointless or quit
and go work somewhere else that's really
it
already noted yeah all right mo
thank you you got it bro see you later
you